I'm so excited to
be here today,
and, I am talk talking to you
from Detroit, Michigan,
United States.
But I, as Arie
mentioned, I work,
in Tennessee.
So I have a PhD in computer
science from Wayne
State University,
and I started working for,
the Oak Ridge
National Lab Center
for Biomedical Informatics at
University of Tennessee Health
Science Center.
We're also affiliated with Le
Bonheur Children's Hospital.
we work in
the Research Foundation
Institute. so we're affiliated
with that as well.
And, me and my team,
we are working in
the population
health intelligence lab.
We're quite
multi multidisciplinary
team, and,
we we I work for doctor Arash
Shapanijad. this talk is based
on a recent journal article I
published in,
GMIR Journal for
Biomedical Informatics.
And, the motivation for this
work was based on a family
resilience initiative
started in,
about now, like,
almost two years ago,
and, it's a screening program
for adverse
childhood experiences
and social determinants
of health.
And then the rest
of the talk,
I'm just gonna be referring to
those as ACs and SDOWADGE.
The program addresses social
needs through
community outreach
coordinators, and
they have a strong,
resource referral
referral network.
And they have these quarterly
reports where they
show statistics
of cases that have
been enrolled
in the program,
and they also have descriptive
anecdotes of the the clients
that have been coming
to the clinic.
And so it's voluntary.
It happens right
after the primary
care visit, And, they,
they detect issues,
such as, you know,
when it comes to
adverse childhood
experiences, they
detect issues
related to child
behavioral issues.
When it comes to
social determinants
of health, the most prevalent
issues are housing,
food insecurities,
and so on. And in terms of
follow-up activities
with their
referral networks,
they do follow-up appointments
with psychiatric
psych you know,
psychological appointments or
clinical appointments
and so on.
And so the the current process
is semi automated or manual in
in for the most case.
And, we wanted to provide them
with a tool that
can help automate
the screening process.
and so I just wanted
to highlight that,
you know, some of
the challenges
in digital health is that we
want to design
intelligent tools,
and that,
will reduce the effort done by
users both in
data entry and in
knowledge acquisition.
And users could be, you know,
caregivers, talking
to the, you know,
health care professional about
their issues and
the the health
care professional itself,
himself or herself
in the knowledge
acquisition process,
and what do they do with this
collected knowledge.
And so we really want good,
data input modalities.
And, in in Michigan mission
critical areas like medicine,
we also want to
provide explanations
of why this decision was made
to provide, you know,
transparency and,
trustworthiness.
now the the current
process is based off standard
questionnaires that they have
developed and agreed upon for
social determinants and other
childhood experiences.
They have a lot of questions
that caregivers have
to go through.
These questions are not only
overwhelming, but
also sometimes
irrelevant. And,
sometimes there
are hidden issues
that the caregiver is not even
aware of that we
want to uncover
in those conversations.
And so these tools
are good for
spotting the issues,
but we need tools to,
help people navigate,
help the caregivers navigate
those in need to resources,
and we want those
tools to mimic
human intelligence.
And one way to you know,
the most important aspect that
humans use to make
decisions is context.
So context is key.
And we also want to be able to
explain why
a decision was made.
So, we need to provide
an explanation,
and we want for
that explanation
to be based on
evidence, you know,
research or public
knowledge, evidence.
And one way to
achieve, you know,
explainability in AI,
and I'm sure so many people in
the conference
today and yesterday
and the day before have been
talking about
knowledge graphs.
And I know,
you probably by now
know the importance
of knowledge graphs
and what they mean.
But just briefly,
because we wanted
to build a tool,
you know, we wanted to,
utilize knowledge graphs for
building that tool for AI
explainability.
And so, you know,
one way to define knowledge is
that it's, you know,
it's data or facts associated
with context.
In context, one way to look at
context is a it's
an overloaded term,
but, well,
one way is to define it by
semantics or metadata that it
describe those facts and put
conversations in context.
and so, knowledge
graphs help,
open the black box in AI.
And, the other
important aspect
of knowledge graphs is they
generalize based on structures
on structure
rather than data,
which is what classic machine
learning does in
training models and,
you know, trying them
on new new data.
And so, in terms
of applications,
digital assistants or chatbots
or conversation agents,
there are many terms.
They incorporate
knowledge graphs
into dialogue interactions.
And so users would be would be
the input from the user would
be data and context,
and those serve as parameters
to queries. We
run those queries
by knowledge graphs.
We personalize
and enrich those
knowledge graphs.
And then,
the other application
is recommendation systems that
can use those query results to
detect personalized resource
suggestions. and
so our approach
for AI explainability
is both,
it's knowledge driven.
It's it uses
knowledge graphs,
but it's but it's
also evidence based.
So we would like to provide
explanations both
based on the graph
structure and past
traceability,
but also based on,
you know, research,
published or, you know,
trials registered.
And so we want to provide some
quantitative, data.
And so starting
from the bottom,
we have been working
on something
that we called knowledge based
urban population
health observatory.
So we collect evidence,
and this evidence
is not individual
level evidence.
It's public evidence.
It's community
level indicators
collected from several sources
like US Census surveys
and, you know,
Esri and CDC. And,
we also have local community
partners such as
Memphis Property Hub,
where we have
data about things
like transportation,
things like walkability scores
in your neighborhood,
and that is a different level
of geographic granularity.
So ZIP codes, census tract,
and census per group levels,
and sometimes at
the, you know,
the the the parcel level.
And so we, we have
been collecting
that data about we call them
social determinants of health
for a while now,
and we have been
doing a lot of
association studies,
linking those to
health outcomes.
And on on the top
of that, we,
you know so we we
process that raw data,
and we try to come up with
epidemiological, you know,
metric metric scores,
like affinity scores and,
results of association
analysis.
And so that's
the evidence that
we're collecting.
And, also, we utilize semantic
web technologies
such as ontologies.
We define epidemiological
ontologies,
surveillance ontologies, and,
we use those to do
semantic inference.
And we feed
concepts from those
ontologies into
building knowledge
graphs as well.
And so that provides
a good base
for applications.
And so going to the top,
we, you know,
we expose the results
through APIs,
and there are so
many technologies
out there to,
query graphs or,
you know, either locally or
globally depending
on the domain.
And then, we provide
explanations.
So we provide
recommendations,
but we also explain those.
And because we
perform different
kind of analysis
techniques, either,
you know, causal inference or
association, regressed through
regression analysis,
we can pull the results,
and we can actually provide
explanations of why we made
certain recommendations.
And we feed those
into the applications
such as digital assistance and
recommended systems,
and we can even
do analytics on
aggregated data
based on previous
conversations.
and so, you know,
since this is this
is not, you know,
a research conference,
I just wanted to
highlight that
we in in building this tool of
utilized several
technologies,
and you probably,
heard about some of this in
the in the conference.
So I to build the ontology,
we utilized to build the QA
agent or the chatbot.
We utilized Google
Dialogflow and,
also the the Google
Cloud platform.
And for the knowledge graph,
we utilize the Neo
four g graph
technology and
a couple of plugins
associated with that
technology as well.
As for the anthology,
it was developed by,
previous post doc
that was working
with my PI, and he,
in that anthology,
he encoded epidemiological
knowledge related to social
determinants of health,
adverse childhood
experiences,
and how those cause certain
negative health outcomes and
what kind of interventions we
can do in order to
mitigate those,
outcomes. And the ontology
includes both concept
hierarchies.
And I'm sure through
the conference
today, you've you've,
seen several ontologies
and, you know,
what they mean.
But, this is a very
conceptual diagram,
but, it's a it's
a comprehensive
ontology of both
concept hierarchies,
object properties
between the different
context as well as,
data type properties
and also,
you know, axioms,
epidemiological
causal relationships
through axioms.
And in building
this ontology,
we, or young, he,
he referred to those standard
questionnaires,
and so he relied
on surveys on,
basic foundation
research papers
on the topic, and,
he also published
the anthology in RDFS,
OWL format on Pyoportals.
It's available and, you know,
for use by other researchers.
And he did reuse
existing ontologies,
but, we we wanted to put that
ontology into use
into a tool.
And so, moving to
the QA agent,
as I said, we utilized Google
Dialogflow. And,
for those who are not familiar
with this framework,
just like IBM Watson and other
frameworks, we
have to start by,
building an agent.
So we have to
define an agent,
and let's say we
have I'm working
on different
application domains.
One domain is this
AC civilians.
Then I have to, you know,
I have to define an agent for
each specific problem.
And within that agent,
I have to train the agent on
certain training phrases that
might come up in
the conversations.
And, you know,
the Google dial dialogue flow
is pretty mature in terms of
natural language
processing, you know,
they have, machine learning
model capability,
training capabilities
already built in.
they already have,
types that are
system defined.
So, they know things like age
and gender.
We don't need to tell,
the framework about
these concepts.
But for our specific problem,
we had to train
the agent on our
concepts the main
concepts from
our domain ontology,
the ACs and social determinant
of health ontology.
And so we need to
define entity types.
We need to load the agent with
those entity types,
and we need to
train it on certain
phrases.
And, so I'm going
to talk about
all of this next.
the first step, you know,
training the chatbot on those
domain content concepts.
As I said, Google
utilizes natural
language processing
to do that.
But, if let's say this is one
of the scenarios
that came up and,
you know, and was inspired by
the quarterly
reports of the Fry
initiative. So,
within this sentence,
it's, you know, it's a text,
but there are certain concepts
that we wanted the agent to be
able to detect.
And so whenever, you know,
whenever the agent
sees the word
alcoholic, it
should be detected
as a substance abuse.
So this is an entity type,
and alcoholic is
a parameter value.
And that's so
that's that appears
in the current
conversation and
the current context.
And so,
the the we told we
told the framework
that this is,
a concept based
on our ontology.
So our ontology
covers that concept.
same thing, calm, you know,
I can't calm my child down.
He bounces back.
This is a symptom.
These are symptoms.
So anything in brown
is a symptom.
four year old as a phrase,
this is detected by Google as
a as an age. So that's why we
see that it says, prefix.
It's like a system.
sex, the same thing.
So there are
things that Google
is able to detect,
and that makes it
easier for us.
But, substance
abuse, symptom,
these are things.
stress is a is
an outcome is a negative
health outcome.
It's not a disease,
but it's a negative
health outcome,
and that is encoded
in the ontology.
So that's about the training.
now about
the the other important
aspect in developing chatbots
is this thing called intent.
So, for example,
within an agent,
within an application
domain, if,
let's say,
the person is talking
about a problem,
I would like to
be able to keep
track of what
their context is,
and I want to keep
all of the active
context on a stack.
So if they say I have
housing issues,
then, housing it
looks like this
person is looking
for a housing
recommendation.
And so in general,
this is an FRI or
family resilience
initiative
recommendation intent,
but this the the child intent
or the specific intent within
that generic intent
is a housing
recommendation.
He's not looking
she's not looking for,
food insecurities.
She's looking for housing
recommendations.
So that's there's this concept
of parent child
intent detection.
And, as I said,
each at each point in
the conversation,
there is one, you know, one,
one intent we're
working with,
but we want we want to keep
track of all
historical intents
that have been detected.
And so we call these
active contacts.
So Google data
flow keeps track
of those.
and but, of course,
we have we must have defined
those at the beginning, but,
it it keeps detecting
the intents
at each step in
the conversation.
So, in addition to detecting
intents and keeping
them on a stack
of active contexts,
the the agent should detect as
we said the contextual
parameters.
And so, you know,
three eight one zero three is
a ZIP code, so that's a system
system type. twenty one years
old is an age that's
a system type.
But housing circumstance,
you know,
is an entity type in
this conversation,
so that's detected
as an entity type.
And the parameters are we have
three parameters that
have that type.
So we have mold.
She suffers from
housing issues.
In particular, she
has mold, bugs,
and inadequate heating.
Again, so
housing circumstances
is a type defined
in our ontology.
And so, the intent detection,
active context, and
context parameters,
and their entity types.
All of that is,
is the is is kept track of.
And going forward in
the conversation,
if, let's say, we
reached a stage
where we are ready to schedule
an appointment,
then we have to,
we ask the person,
would you like me to schedule
an appointment?
And if they say
yes, I start an,
you know, an action
or an event.
And so I have to
call, you know,
the the the intent that is
responsible for that action.
And for that purpose,
I need the time.
I need the the appointment
type.
Is it a psychological
appointment?
Is it a clinical appointment?
I need the date
and time and for
how long. And so,
there is something
called the slot
filling, context.
And, in in
conversation agents,
we you know, in in
these platforms,
you we can we can
say that these
are the mandatory parameters.
These are optional
parameters.
You know, they
can the the user
can skip some of them and but
some of them are important.
And for the for those that are
important for
the appointment,
we can link them to
friendly questions.
For example, we can say,
can you please provide
me with a date?
Can you please provide
me with a time?
So that's something
we can work
with through those platforms.
But I'm just showing
the, you know,
the technical, aspects,
behind the scenes,
what happens behind
the scenes.
So to the left is what
a user would see,
and to the right
is what happens
within the dialogue
flow framework.
the third, thing,
and that's very important,
is how how do we
lay all of this
information over
to our, you know,
recommendation or
knowledge graph,
you know, generation
service or,
you know, back end
component is through,
again, this is done through
the Google Cloud
platform through
something called
fulfillments.
And so, a fulfillment
is simply,
you know, it's it's
like a service
that could be either
user defined.
So we could define our own
recommendation service
endpoint and,
you know, for those who use
Google Cloud
platform that you're
probably familiar with this.
So we have to define our own
service and what it does,
but we can also
utilize the Google
Cloud platform APIs.
and that's one of the reasons
why I chose this platform.
For example, if I
want to schedule
an appointment,
I could invoke
the Google Calendar
API and do the you know,
I I could trigger the calendar
app on the user side
and, you know,
they can just
automatically add
the appointment.
I can involve
the Google Places
API if I want to
look for clinics
around. So I don't
have to redefine.
I don't have to
reinvent the wheel.
I can use existing APIs.
And so that's simply,
that's what fulfillment does.
So it's like an intermediary,
component there
for communication
between the chatbot
and whatever
other services I would like to
use such as Neo four
g and, you know,
those other components.
And so that's for the agent or
the chatbot. Now,
through the fulfillment,
we pass over
the parameters and
their entity types
to the knowledge
graph. So now we have data in
terms of values, and
we have, you know,
context in terms of
those entity types.
So we have concepts and data.
And so we would
like to do to,
you know, to to build a graph
that is personalized to this
specific user,
and we would like
to enrich that graph gradually
and populate it with values or
facts or data,
that the user did
not even mention
in the conversation.
And for that purpose,
we used we collect evidence,
as I mentioned earlier,
through this observatory or
through publicly
available research,
articles. And so I would like
to talk more about
this knowledge
graph component.
So, as I said, we you know,
within this conversation,
if the person said,
I am Hispanic,
female living in
Memphis in this
ZIP code. My six
year old child
experiences night terror.
I don't have a car.
If she mentions
those, you know,
those words in
the text that she
provides in the in the chat,
in the conversation,
I can start off with
those concepts.
So I can start with those by
adding you know,
I can create a personalized
graph for her. So I start by
adding those parameters,
contextual parameters
in purple.
So all these circles,
Hispanic three eight
one zero three.
So these are things
that, you know,
she mentioned.
And then I start
linking those parameter values
to their entity types
based on concepts,
you know, either common sense
concepts or
concepts defined in
my anthology. And so,
Hispanic is a race,
so that's,
you know, it's the value is
Hispanic and it's a race.
And three eight one zero three
is a ZIP code, and,
six years old is
in this context
is an age, and,
night terror is a symptom.
So symptom here is an example
of a concept that is
not common sense.
It's something
that I we define
in the anthologies,
and so it's that's
why it's in blue.
So that's something that we
detected in
the conversation as
an entity type.
Now the next step is to start
populating the graph with more
and more nodes based on this,
concept hierarchy hierarchical
relationships, you know,
those object
properties defined
in the ontology.
So for example,
three eight one zero three as
a ZIP code represents
a neighborhood.
So that's a neighborhood,
And a neighborhood has,
I'm just gonna to
be able to point.
So this is a neighborhood,
and a neighborhood
has physical
characteristics. And physical
characteristics
could be workability
scores, crime rate,
and blight prevalence,
you know,
signs of destruction
in the neighborhood
. And so,
I can add more and more edges
and notes based on what I can
infer from
the the the anthology.
And another example
is that six
as an age is a school age.
She did not say that
in the conversation
, but I can I can
enrich the graph
by adding that external and
the relationship?
And so these are just
simple examples,
but this is an example of how
I how I infer extra knowledge
to enrich and
refine the graph.
and the last step is I start
populating those
notes with values.
So, for example,
how do I know that three eight
one zero three
what is the value
for a workability
score in three
eight one zero three?
It's from this pop population
observatory that
we're building.
So we have, data
for, you know,
for each ZIP code.
I can retrieve all of these
characteristics,
community level
characteristics
publicly available
to populate the graph
with values
or facts.
and, so that's what,
the graph is gonna look like
after a while. And as I said,
each node is color coded based
on where we get
those nodes from,
and the edges could be direct
because they were mentioned or
in you know, they could be
indirect because
they were inferred.
And, so that's,
and I'm gonna go back to this
later on for,
explaining more things.
Now, once we're done
with the knowledge
graph generation,
now we it's time to start
providing recommendations.
So for this
particular scenario
and application,
we we thought of two kinds of
recommendations. So one one
thing is what is you know,
based on all of those
detected issues,
what is the next question that
the QA agent should
be asking the user?
So what's the next follow-up
question that is
relevant to this user?
We don't want to
overwhelm them
with a lot of questions.
What is the most recommended
questions to ask next?
Or if we are more
towards the end
of the conversation
and we know
that we what
the person is mostly
concerned about,
we could recommend resources,
so clinics, appointments,
and and so on.
And, we also would
like to provide
explanations. So
we want to keep
track of how we made
the recommendation,
and that's also
done on the graph.
So I'm just gonna talk about
this specific part next.
So in terms of personalized
recommendations,
I'm just gonna
go back to this graph that I
showed earlier,
and I'm showing the right side
of the graph just
for clarity.
So this person
said that her six
year old child has
night terrors.
And so as I said,
we had populated
the graph with
the fact that six is an age,
and it's a school age.
So one question that comes up
in AC's questionnaires is,
does your child suffer from
bullying at school?
If I know that six
is a school age,
then I should ask
this question next.
If not, I should
just skip it.
And that's one
example of I how
I can refine the questions.
another example is, you know,
this thing about uncovering
hidden issues. For example,
she said night terror.
Night terror is
a symptom based
on my ontology.
But I know from
my ontology that
night terror as a symptom is
caused by emotional neglect.
This is something I
encoded both as,
you know, a concept,
and I encoded
the relationship,
so the causality
relationship.
So emotional neglect causes
night terror. Now I'm not sure
if this user if
this is the case
with this user,
but I would like
to ask her that
question next. So
I might ask her,
does your child suffer
from, you know,
emotional neglect?
Or I could bring it
up in a different
way. One of the questions that
comes up in
the questionnaire is,
have you recently
separated from
your husband?
So I could ask it
in a, you know,
in a more friendly way.
And, if she says yes,
we can follow-up
on that question.
If she say says no,
we can move to the,
you know, to the to the next,
next stage where we can start
suggesting
psychiatry clinics.
And, so I can ask her,
would you like so now this is
not a question.
This is a resource.
So I ask her, would
you like, here are,
you know, a couple
of psychiatric
clinics within and I
can't personalize.
So I can say this is these are
the clinics within
your ZIP code area,
and they also have a Spanish
speaking services, you know,
based on the fact that she
provided those two
context the contextual
parameters about ZIP code and
the fact that she's Hispanic.
So this is an example
of how how
I can personalize
and how a suggestion
can be either a resource
or a follow-up
question. Now the other aspect
is explanations.
So, this is now the left side
of the graph for clarity.
So this is the same person who
was talking. Now
she did not say
anything about
social determinants
of of health. All what she was
talking about was related to
adverse childhood experiences
and behavioral issues.
But the fact that she lives in
three zero two e
three eight one
zero three can
give me a lot of
information just based on her
neighborhood.
I can do a lot here.
I can as I said
earlier, I can say,
well, this is a ZIP code that
presents a neighborhood that
suffers from this
much crime rate,
this much destruction in terms
of neighborhood quality,
and it has this
walkability score.
And I can populate
those with values.
And if if, let's
say, you know,
blight is the highest,
then I can say,
well, you know,
she might be living she might
be one of one of
the aspects of
measuring blight
rate or, you know,
this, neighborhood
quality aspect
is something called lead lead
paint based exposure
risk score.
And, so they
calculate the score
based on several things.
One of them is that that she's
living in a house
that might be
might be painted with a lead
based paint, and that could
expose her to toxicants.
And the exposure to toxicants
might cause a negative health
outcomes like asthma.
And so I could do all of this
behind the scenes
and then give
her a follow-up question that
she did not even was
not even aware of.
I could ask her,
would you you know,
does anybody in your household
suffer from asthma?
And if she says yes,
I can directly,
give her resource suggestions
of asthma clinics.
If the if if it's her child,
then I can suggest pediatric
asthma clinics.
And I can, again,
personalize based on her ZIP
code and her, ethnicity.
And, you know,
I can trace I can
trace back on this.
So this is an example
of something
she did not mention,
and I want to show the person
behind the chat who's talking
to the user why I came up with
all of this. So
I can trace back
on the graph and come up with
this path of reasoning of why
I made you know,
I suggested for
the health care
practitioner to
ask that question
or suggest those resources.
And so I can this is this is
the the beauty of graphs.
I can always
provide the path.
It's it's it's
it's white box.
It's not black box.
And so in in going forward to
developing the tool,
we wanted a tool design that
reflects all of this.
So, yes, we want
this chat box,
chatbot to be available
to the end user.
In this case, it's the child
parent or the caregiver,
but we also wanted to provide
all of these
recommendations to
the health care
practitioner or
social worker depending
on the domain.
And we want also to
provide, you know,
policymakers with
explanations and,
you know, aggregated
analytics.
And so before even thinking of
the tool design,
this is just a prototype.
So before thinking
about the design,
we wanted to see what
we want to show.
And so, eventually,
we want to
provide recommendations
in in in the health domain.
They call them interventions,
which could be
either therapeutic
or preventive.
And, things like, you know,
schedule an appointment with
an asthma clinic
pediatric asthma
clinic. This is a this
is an intervention
. And we when we personalize,
we give preferences.
So we say
the preferences is we
want this to be near the ZIP
code with this language
speaking skills.
And then we want to,
be keep track of
everything that
we detected in
the conversation.
Symptoms are important.
So we want to keep
track of those from,
you know, a health
perspective,
and we want to detect
risk factors.
Again, risk factors
is a, you know,
is a is a concept
used in the medical
field.
So risk factors,
that appeared in this woman's
conversations where
things like blights,
you know, being living
in a neighborhood
with a high plight rating,
this is a social
determinant of health.
Night terror as a symptom
represents a behavioral issue
that is related to adverse
childhood experiences because
we wanted this tool to also be
a surveillance tool.
So we want to keep
track of symptoms,
risk factors,
and also what are
the negative health outcomes
that we inferred in
this conversation.
Asthma was one of them.
and then we want to provide
explanations. And in providing
explanation, we
want to provide
the source of evidence,
how we came up with
this explanation.
And so we want to say
that the neighborhood
with blights, you know,
coming up with this was based
on the ontological reasoning,
but we came up with
applied value,
the the rating white rating
value from this
observatory that
we collected from population
level datasets.
So we want to
provide the source
of evidence, and we want them
to be able to
navigate and look
into those, you
know, numbers.
And when we said
that lead exposure,
leads to asthma or
causes asthma,
that's something
we came up from
based on the ontology.
And so we we will we want to
provide them with
a link to this
ontology, and
they can actually
look at it depending on their
literacy level
and how much they
are interested.
But we need for this
to be available.
And, we also want
to, explain,
you know so in addition to
detecting health outcomes,
we detected a cause
of a symptom.
We detected that
emotional neglect
causes, night terror and,
both asthma and
emotional neglect
were detected based
on inference.
So they were not given.
They were inferred.
And in explaining this
part, we can say,
well, this based
on this causal
relationship between emotional
neglect and night terror,
and the resource for evidence
is the ontology.
And so the, the last thing I
wanna talk about
is the the tool
design that we thought of,
and it's really preliminary,
and we're working
on, you know,
refining and revising it.
But the the there
are two views
of this tool.
The first view is
which provides,
you know, the recommendations
and the explainability
and the detection
of social determinants,
risk factors,
ACs, and all of that, and,
the analytics, the aggregated
analytics based
on all previous
conversations,
that is something
that we would like the health
care professional
or the policymaker
to look at. And,
example of explanations,
as I said.
so for example here, the,
the health care
practitioner can,
For example, when we said that
the this patient
has the following,
risk, you know, symptoms,
the risk factors,
exposure to lead based pains,
that a patient has
a certain risk score,
and, the fact that they should
be screened for asthma.
So all of that is you know,
these are suggestions.
But if they want
to explain this,
they can click on
a question mark,
you know, to
explain why we made
these decisions, and,
we can, you know,
show them a pop up or, like,
a different view
where they can
see why we made this.
So one way of explaining this
is based on semantic
inference,
and we can provide a brief
description of, you know,
the causal relationship and
the link to
the ontology if they
would like to look at it.
And, if let's say
this conversation
detected four behavioral
aspects about,
you know, that this
child suffers from,
then we can give
them an adverse
childhood experience
score four
because there were there were
four answers.
You know? We asked them four
follow-up questions,
and they said yes
to all four,
then we can give
them this score.
And if, you know,
they can decide
if this is a is
a high score or a low score or
what they should do based on
the score based on
the literature.
So we can give
them article DOIs
so they can pull up articles,
authentic articles
about AEs and
health outcomes.
so this is
an example of how we
provide explanations.
And as I said, you know,
we can provide geocoded,
since this is a tool,
resource suggestions
of clinics
or housing authorities within
their ZIP code,
and we can show it on a map.
and, for the the end user or
the the the caregiver,
we can give them,
you know, we can load these
suggestions into
the chat box,
and we can either do this
automatically or
give the health
care practitioner
the option to,
you know, approve that this is
the next question or not.
Because this is, you know,
this is something that
needs evaluation.
So we can we can try this with
a few scenarios and
see what works best.
But, this is
an example of what
I was talking about earlier of
the power of the Google Cloud
Platform APIs through
fulfillment.
So we can integrate
Google Maps
or Google Places in
the conversation.
We can integrate
Google Calendar
in the conversations,
in order to provide those
recommendations. And so we're
working on,
evaluating this and trying to
bring it to realization with
the Afarai initiative,
team at La Bonner.
And, we're looking
to, you know,
get, funding for actually
implementing the entire tool,
and and integrated in clinical
workflows. thank
you so much for
listening, and this is the end
of my presentation.